[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راوي القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوانبه نبدا بابرز العناوين
اعتراض عشرات الصواريخ من غزه بعد تصعيد
اسرائيلي ونتنياهو يؤكد ان المعركه لم
تنتهي
الملك سلمان يوجه دعوه للاسد للمشاركه
بقمه جده والرئيس السوري يؤكد ان القمه
ستعزز العمل العربيه المشترك
يا تتحدث عن تراجع للقوات الروسيه في بخمس
بعد هجوم مضاده
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
[موسيقى]
اشتداد المعارك في الخرطوم والجيش
السوداني يسيطر على مواقع للدعم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم نبدا من اخر التطورات في قطاع
غزه فقط زودت صافرات الانذار في مستوطنات
الغلاف بعد اطلاق عشرات الصواريخ من
القطاع وذلك في اطار رد حركه الجهاد
الاغتيال ثلاثه من قادتها العسكريين امس
بغارات ادت لسقوط قتلى وجرح مدنيين رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو قال
قبل قليل ان المعركه لم تنتهي حتى الان
واضاف ان اسرائيل اصابت اهدافا بدقه مشيرا
الى ان المعادله الامنيه الجديده هي ان تل
ابيب ستحدد الوقت المناسب لاستهداف قاده
الفصائل الفلسطينيه
نحن في خضم المعركه قوتنا تقوم بتوجيه
ضربات قويه وندمر كل من يمس بنا او يعمل
ضدنا هذا هو المبدا الذي نتعامل به في
اطار عمليه الدرع والسهم اوجدنا معادله
جديده نقول للمخربين ومرسليهم نراكم في كل
مكان ولا تستطيعون الاختباء ونحن نختار
المكان والزمان الذي نضربكم خلاله نحن
ولستم انتم بهدوء وليس كرد فعل الخيار لنا
انزلنا على الجهاد في غزه اقوى ضربه في
تاريخها
[موسيقى]
وانضم الينا من حدود قطاع غزه مدير مكتب
العربيه في فلسطين اهلا بك زياد يعني منذ
قرابه الساعه تبعنا يعني مؤتمرا صحافيا
لنتنياهو ما ابرز ما ورد في هذا المؤتمر
الصحفي وما فرص نجاح ان كان مساعي المصريه
او الامميه في التوصل لوقف الاطلاق النار
بالساعات القليله القادمه
اجتهد نيتنياه كثيرا في المؤتمر الصحفي في
ان يسوق انجازا
للاسرائيليين اساسا وللقواعد اليمنيه
بالحديث عن ارساء معادله جديده وهي ان
اسرائيل
تغتال وتختار موعد وطريقه الاغتيال
لقيادات وكوادر الفصائل الفلسطينيه
والاجنحه العسكريه الفلسطينيه بطبيعه
الحال الاغتيالات الاسرائيليه هي عمرها من
الستينات وحتى اليوم اسرائيل دائما كانت
تقوم باغتيالات خارج وداخل الجغرافيا
الفلسطينيه
وبالتالي طبعا هذا الحديث بدا موجه اكثر
للراي العام في اسرائيل بان تمت متغيرا
هذه المره يختلف عن عشرات جولات التصعيد
التي تبدا وتنتهي على الشاكله ذاتها قام
قد يحدث مع هذه الجوله فيما خاصه قضيه وقف
اطلاق النار عمليا هناك صعوبات في الساعات
الاخيره بدات تطرا على هذا الموضوع هذا لا
يعني بان ذلك قد يكون بعيدا المنال
بالضروره ولكن حركه الجهاد الاسلامي عمليا
وفق المصادر المختلفه مررت للمصريين طلبا
بان تقوم اسرائيل بتسليم جثمان عمليا
القياده
خضر عدنان الذي كان توفي في سجن
الاسرائيلي وجثمين عدد ايضا من مقاتلي
الجهاد التي تحتفظ فيه اسرائيل او عدم
عمليا تقوم باحتجازهم لديها هذا المطلب
عمليا لم تستجب له اسرائيل بعد بالاضافه
الى ايضا التزام او اعلان اسرائيلي
بالالتزام بوقف سياسه الاغتيال وما الى
ذلك هذه الصعوبات كانت متوقعه للغايه
عمليا من الطرفين هناك الطالب تمرر وتحاول
ان ترسم الحدود بالنار عمليا عبر استمرار
التصعيد في الساعه الاخيره على اي حال
بدات تخفت نوعا ما
عمليه تبادل القصف ما بين القوات
الاسرائيليه والفصائل الفلسطينيه يعني
ربما قبل 20 او 30 دقيقه كانت اخر رشقه
صاروخيه رصدناها من قطاع غزه تجاه
المستوطنات الغلاف قطاع غزه هنا على
الحدود زياد
الملاحظ بالرشاقات الاخيره للصواريخ هو
اصاباتها المباشره لمنازل ونقاط مباني
بعسقلان هل ذلك يعود الى ارباك باعتراض
القبه الحديديه لتلك الرشقات الصاروخيه او
ربما يعني
للخبره التي اكتسبتها الفصائل الفلسطينيه
بتوجيه الضربات كيف يمكن تفسير ذلك
هذا صحيح هذا منحا لتفسير ربما يكون
منطقيا جدا راينا في اللحاء حرب الاخيره
ايضا مثلا تركيز هائل كان على عسقلان
بالذات
يعني اكثر من 150 صاروخا اطلقت تباعا تجاه
القبه الحديديه لم تفلح في اعتراض
الصواريخ جميع الصواريخ وكان هناك تدمير
واصابات هذا التكرر بشكل او باخر كميه
كبيره من الصواريخ تطلق تجاه منطقه معينه
تربك عمليا عمليه الاعتراض بالنسبه للقبه
الحديديه وبالتالي تسقط صواريخ كان هناك
سته عشر مصابا في معظمهم بحالات هلا ولكن
هناك اصابات ايضا نقلت الى مشفى برزيلي في
مدينه عسقلان في المنطقه الحدوديه وكان
هناك اصابات في اكثر من مستوطنه حقيقه
لمنازل ولفناء بعض المنازل تسببت باضرار
ماديه جسيمه هذه الصواريخ واساسا في المره
الماضيه ايضا اسرائيل كانت تقرت بعد القبه
الحديديه كان بها خلل فني ماء ادى الى سوق
اداء ولكن ادعت بان ذلك جرى اصلاحه عمليا
في المره الماضيه
هل هناك من معلومات متوفره حول نقاط
الخلاف التي يعني توقف حتى الان التوصل
الى اتفاق هدنه لانه هناك حديث بانه
الفلسطينيين يصرون على ان تتوقف اسرائيل
عن سياسه الاغتيالات
هذا صحيح هناك يعني هذه الخلافات كما ستفت
قبل قليل ممكن ان تكون في هذا الاتجاب
اساسا قضيه وقف الاغتيالات وطبعا عندما
توقف اسرائيل النار وتتعهد بذلك هي ستوقف
الاغتيالات ولكن في المحصله ربما المطالبه
من قبل الجهاد بتسليم جثمين لمقاتلين
قتلتهم اسرائيل وايضا اساسا
للشيخ خضر عدنان عمليا على وجه الخصوص هي
تريد ان تقوم اسرائيل بالافراج عن جثماني
هذا الموضوع قد يكون مربكا جدا ومحرجا جدا
لنتنياهو امام اليمين يعني قد يهاجم اذا
ما قام بذلك ولهذا قد تكون هناك صعوبه في
هذا الموضوع ربما يكون ترتيبات ومخارج
اخرى ان يكون بشكل غير متعلق ومباشر
بالجوله لاحقا ان يتم ذلك هذا ايضا وارد
في هذه الحسابات يعني هناك دائما مخارج
للمفاوضين في هذه المتجهات عمليا يمكن ان
تتم ولكن بدون ان نشك في الساعات الاخيره
على الاقل يمكن ان نتحدث عن صعوبات تعترض
الوسيطه المصري امام اقناع الطرفين
بالقبول بالاعلان المتبادل والمتزامن لوقف
اطلاق النار لكن عمليا كلما مرت الساعات
ويعني جرى الامر ذاته من تبادل القصف هذا
قد يقود في نهايه المحصله اذا لم تحدث
مفاجات في هذه العمليه من تبادل القصف
بمعنى اذا لم تقع
الضحايا في قطاع غزه بشكل كبير او لم تكن
هناك اصابات مباشره وربما مقتل مستوطنين
هذا الامر يبقي الباب مواربا امام امكانيه
فعليه للتواصل في نهايه المطاف لوقف اطلاق
النار كما قلنا كلا الطرفين يحاول قبيل
الوصول الى وقف اطلاق النار زياده اشتعال
النيران كي يقول بان عمليا يده كانت
العليا والطوله في المواجهه
حلبي مدير مكتب العربيه في فلسطين هذه
المعلومات الوافيه
هذا وطلبه المانيا بوقف فوري للتصعيد في
غزه واشار المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الالمانيه انه لا حل للازمه على المدى
البعيد الا عبر تطبيق القرارات الدوليه
فيما يخص حل الدولتين
يحق لسكان قطاع غزه واسرائيل العشاء بسلام
وكرامه ان موقف المانيا من هذا الامر
معروف ومن الممكن تحقيق هذا الهدف عبر خلق
اطار جاد للتفاوض للوصول الى حل الدولتين
انما الان فالمطلوب هو وقف التصعيد فورا
ومنع زياده اعداد الضحايا وهذا الامر من
واجب جميع الاطراف الموجوده على الارض
تواصل اسرائيل شن غارات على قطاع غزه
وتنتظر على المنحى الاخر انتهاء رد
الفصائل الفلسطينيه لانهاء حاله الترقب
التي يعيشها مئات الالاف من الاسرائيليين
في المدن المحاذيه وسط ذلك كل يشكو اهالي
القطاع من صوت طائرات الاستطلاع التي
يسميها المواطنون الزنانه
ويعتبرونها نذير شؤم ومصدرا دائما للتوتر
والازعاج
[موسيقى]
انه الصوت السائد في غزه على مدار 24 ساعه
وثقه المواطنون بهواتفهم منهم من وصفه
بصوت اللعين ونذير الشؤم واخر كتب اشعر ان
خلايا مخية تنفجر
للخوف
بعدم الاطماني الاطمانينه هذه الزنانات
يعني بتغادرش الاجواء بالليل مرهقانا في
البيت في العمل في كل مكان
يعيش اكثر من مليوني غزااوي تحت رحمه
طائرات الاستطلاع الاسرائيليه يسمونها في
غزه الزنانه لما تصدره من صوت مزعج
وفي اسرائيل اسطول متنوع منها هيرمس وجدان
وايتان
منها ما يراقب ومنها ما يلقي بحممه بامر
من غرفه التحكم هذه
ممكن تقتله وتدمر بيوت زي اللي صار في
التصعيد اللي احنا موجودين فيه الان نفس
هذه الزنانه وهذه الطائره في نفسها اللي
اطلقت على بيوت زي البيت اللي في رفح بيت
غنام نفس هذا صار في استشهاد لكل الاسره
صوت الزنانه يثير رعب غزه لكن صوت الصمت
يثير قلق اسرائيل
على الطرف الاخر انتظروا هذا الصوت صوت
صفارات الانذار لترد الفصائل بالصواريخ
حتى تنتهي جوله التصعيد ويعود لحياتهم
الطبيعيه
[موسيقى]
تتابعون معنا بعد الفاصل
تدشين عده مشاريع في عدن بتمويل من
البرنامج السعودي من بينها مستشفى ومطار
المحافظه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنا البرنامج السعودي
لتنميه واعمار اليمن عن افتتاح حزمه
مشاريع تنمويه وذلك بدعم وتمويل لسبع
قطاعات حيويه تاتي هذه المشاريع التنمويه
الحيويه ضمن 229 مشروع ومبادره تنمويه
سعوديه اشار البيان الى افتتاح مستشفى عدن
العام ومركز القلب الذي بدوره سيخدم نصف
مليون مستفيد سنويا هذا وقد تم تدشين
المرحله الثالثه لمشروع مطار عدن الذي
يشمل اعاده تاهيل المدرج الرئيس والملاحه
طبعا المطار عدن هو احد المشاريع الكبيره
جدا البرنامج ينفذها تيرم المرحله الاولى
والثانيه واليوم مضاعف اقامه الرئيس
المرحله الثالثه
وفور انتهاء المرحله الثالثه سيكون المطار
على اعلى مستويات الدوليه وسيسمح الكثير
من الشركات
باستخدام المطار سواء في السفر من من والى
مطار عدن هذا المطار هو ايضا هناك مطار
الغيظ ايضا وكذلك طريق العبر في حضرموت
ومارب 130 كيلو كذلك هيجت العبد في تعز
اضافه الى مجموعه من المشاريع النقل
الداخليه المختلفه في علم المحافظات
اليمنيه
طبعا هذا التجهيز المستشفى تم بجهود كبيره
وهذه الجهود طبعا تكللت بالنجاح اليوم
وتكلفه اجماليه تجاوزت 25 مليون دولار
طبعا هناك الكثير من المشاريع الاخرى التي
سندشنها وسنفتتح اليوم هناك تدشين اليوم
ووضح حجر الاساس لمطار عدن الدولي
وسيكون هذا المطار ربما من اكبر المطارات
في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
مبادرات مستدامه تهدف الى تمويلها
السعوديه عبر برنامجها في سبعه قطاعات
حيويه ضمن 229 مشروعا من بينها افتتاح
مستشفى عدن العام ومركز القلب الذي سيخدم
نصف مليون سنويا اضافه الى تدشين
المرحلتين الاولى والثانيه لمشروع اعاده
تاهيل مطار عدن الدولي من مدرج عدن رئيسي
الى انظمه الملاحه والاتصالات علما بان
مشاريع اعمار اليمن تجاوزت مليار دولار
امريكي منذ عام 2018
تستفيد منها اربعه عشره محافظه يمنيه
مشاريع من شانها ان تدفع عجله اقتصاد
اليمن وترفع كفاءه قطاعات البلاد
وينضم الينا من القاهره علي الصراري
المستشار السياسي والاعلامي لرئيس الوزراء
اليمني اهلا بك معنا الليله سيد علي يعني
بدايه اهميه هكذا مشاريع التنمويه
ومبادرات سعوديه يعني تستهدف سبع قطاعات
اساسيه وحيويه بالنسبه لليمنيين وبالنسبه
تحديدا لسكان محافظه عدن كونها مبادره
يعني مستدامه وليست اغاثيه مؤقته
مساء الخير وتحيه لك وللمشاهدين الكرام
حقيقه
هذه
فرصه
نستطيع من خلالها ان نتوجه
بالتحيه والشكر لقياده المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
على ما تقدمه من عون
لليمن
وهذه الحزمه من المشاريع التي يجري اليوم
افتتاحها او وضع حجر الاساس لها هي
مشروعات حيويه
ولها اهميه خاصه اولا لانها
ستحدث نقله مهمه في وضع مدينه عدن كعاصمه
مؤقته للجمهوريه اليمنيه
وبالتالي
ستتيح فرصه لتقديم خدمات فيما يتعلق
العلاج يعني من خلال افتتاح
مستشفى عدن ومركز القلب في المستشفى
وبسعه كبيره كما هو معروف الان
وايضا المطار بما سيقدمه ايضا من خدمات
للمسافرين سيحول مطار عدن الى مطار الدولي
على مستوى عالي من الكفاءه والجاهزيه
هذه في تقدير يعني هي يعني اولا مشروعات
هامه وحيويه وخاصه انها تاتي
في ظل يعني
الحرب وما تركته من اثار مدمره هذه يعني
اولا هو نستطيع ان نعتبر ان هذا هو جزء
مهم من تاهيل البنيه الاساسيه
في اليمن بما يساعدها على ان تنهض مره
اخرى وان ترمم الاوضاع بصوره عامه
المساعده السعوديه في الواقع هي لا تقتصر
على هذه المشروعات المقدمه الى عدن وانما
هي تقدم لمحافظه كثيره
وهي يعني
هذه المشاريع هي يعني في مجالات عده
مجالات الصحه والتعليم والنقل
وغيرها من الكهرباء والمياه
هذه كلها هي مشاريع مهمه تحتاجها اليمن
خاصه ان اليمن تعرضت في هذه المجالات
بالذات
لتدمير واسع وهي صارت تحتاج فعلا
يعني ان
تتوسع بهذا الشكل او ذاك في هذه المجالات
الحيويه
سيد علي يعني بالحديث عن مطار عدن وتدشين
المرحله الثالثه منه
بدعم مالي من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
فائده هذا المطار ليس فقط على عدن وانما
على اليمن بشكل عام خاصه اذا ما اخذنا
بعين الاعتبار العوائد او العائدات
الماديه التي ستدر يعني من هذا المطر
لا شك في ذلك اولا
يعني مطار عدن هو مطار اساسي ويمكن من
خلاله
تنظم رحلات الى بقيه المحافظات اليمنيه ثم
ان خدماته لا تقتصر فقط على اليمن ولكن
ايضا بحكم موقع عدن موقعها الجغرافي هي
هي يعني ممكن يعني هي تكون في الوقت ذاته
همزه وصل بعدد من الدول ومن حيث يمكن ان
يستخدم مطار عدن كمحطه على طريق الوصول
الى هذه الدول اذا نلاحظ بان مطار عدن له
اهميه خاصه لليمن عامه
والمنطقه بصوره عامه نظرا للموقع المتميز
لعدن
ويعني
ما يمكن ان يقدمه المطار من خدمات للدول
المجاوره لليمن شكرا جزيلا لك السيد علي
الصراري المستشار السياسي والاعلامي لرئيس
الوزراء اليمني شكرا
[موسيقى]
قالت وكاله الانباء السعوديه ان الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز بعث دعوه الى الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد لحضور القمه العربيه
المقرره في جده في التاسع عشر من مايو
الجريمه وسلم السفير السعودي بالاردن نايف
سديري الدعوه الى الاسد الذي اكد من جهته
ان انعقاد القمه العربيه المقبله في
السعوديه سيعزز العمل العربي المشتركه
لتحقيق تطلعات الشعوب العربيه
[موسيقى]
كقائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه ان هجوما
مضادا لقوته نجح في اجبار القوات الروسيه
في بخنوت على التراجع وقال القائد العسكري
الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه تراجعت
لمسافه تصل الى كيلو مترين في بعض مناطق
هذا واكدت مصادر ان التراجع تم من احياء
في المناطق الغربيه للمدينه
الحرب في اوكرانيا فتحت الباب واسعا امام
شركات التقنيه والسلاح الاصغر حجما
لمزاحمه كبريات الشركات صحيفه
البريطانيه قالت ان شركات مثل ميلان
روبوتيكس الاستونيه
الامريكيه وتيبي كار التركيه بدات تنافس
شركات مثل لوكيد مارتن الامريكيه العملاقه
ومع طول الصراع في اوكرانيا بدات اوكرانيا
بالاستعانه بالشركات الصغيره والمتوسطه
نظرا لتاخر اقرار عقود الشركات الكبيره من
بين الاسلحه التي استغلتها اوكرانيا في
المواجهه مع روسيا الاقمار الصناعيه
المستعاره هي قادره على تغطيه مئات
الكيلومترات كما انها ارخص من نظراتها
التقليديه نوعا اخر من الاسلحه المستخدمه
هو المسيرات الانتحاريه وهي صغيره الحجم
كما نشاهد لدرجه
وضعها في الجيب تخيلوا بالامكان اطلاقها
ايضا باليد لدينا الطائرات المسيره وهي
سلاح اثبت فعاليته قبل واثناء الحرف في
اوكرانيا واخيرا العربات المسيره التي
تقوم بعده مهام منها الاستطلاع والقتال
وازاله الالغام واجلاء الضحايا نجاح هذه
الشركات يؤكد على التغييرات التي تجتاح
صناعه الدفاع لكن هل سيكون هذا النجاح
مستداما الفتره القادمه ستكشف لنا الجواب
لكن تجربه الولايات المتحده في حربي
العراق وايضا افغانستان اظهرت ان الشركات
المتوسطه والصغيره ربما تحاول القيام
باختراق هذا السوق الا ان الشركات الكبرى
تعود لتفرض سطوتها في النهايه وينضم الينا
من موسكو للحديث عن هذا الموضوع
المحلل العسكري الروسي اهلا بك سيد سرغي
يعني اذا اخذنا
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه الاخيره كمثال
كيف غيرت
التكنولوجيا والذكاء الاصطناعي
بمفاهيم الحرب بالادوات حتى الاستراتيجيات
الحربيه التي وضعت لتسيير هذه الحرب
مساء الخير جميعا
بالفعل التكنولوجيات الحديثه غيرت تابع
الحرب وغيرت الاستراتيجيه
والاساليب العملياتيه في استخدام الاسلحه
وحتى الاسلحه بحد ذاتها تغيرت بشكل
جذري على سبيل المثال ان كانت
في السابق
الاسلحه التقليديه هو العمود الفقري
لمختلف الصنوف الجيش وصحتها
الان
تغيرت الصوره بشكل كبير جدا على سبيل
المثال المسيرات التي ذكرتها
ان كان البعض يعتبروها في السابق الشغله
الثانويه روتينيه وحتى لعبه الاطفال
فاصبح من الواضح ان المسيرات الحديثه لها
دور فعال
ودور بالغ الاهميه في على سبيل المثال
الطائرات الاستطلاع الاستراتيجي قادره على
طيران على مدار الساعه
والارتفاعات تصل الى 14 كيلومتر
والتقاط الصور الدقيقه على مسافه 200
كيلومتر يعني حتى رقم السياره لاحد
السياره يمكن التقاطها
من ذلك البعد نفس الشيء ينتابك الصواريخ
موجهه
صواريخ مضاده للدبابات ان كان في السابق
صاروخ يصل الى
2100 متر بالكثير فالان هناك صواريخ موجهه
مضاده للدبابات
يتم اطلاقها الى مدى تصل الى يعني الذكاء
الاصطناعي والتكنولوجيا كان مستخدم بقوه
من الجانب الاوكراني طبعا بدعم غربي مباشر
ويعني كان له دور برايك بقلب الموازين
لصالح اوكرانيا في بعض المعارك وبعض
النقاط
لا شك فان له لا دعم التكنولوجي العسكري
والمادي والاقتصادي الغربي فكانت الصوره
تختلف بصوره جذريه لان على سبيل المثال
الجيش الاوكراني يستلم المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه
بشكل مباشر من الاقمار الصناعيه الامريكيه
وطائرات التجسس الغربيه تزاود الجيش
الاوكراني بحذافيات دقيقه
يعني اي طائره روسيه يتم نقل المعلومات
عنها بعد اقلاعها من القاعده الجويه
مباشره راسا نفس الشيء ينتابك على وسائل
الاتصال على سبيل المثال هناك شركه
ستارلينج الامريكيه المشهوره عالميا اي
سريه سريه مشاه اوكرانيه فيها وسائل
الاتصال عبر الاقمار الصناعيه تبع لشركه
ستارليك وهذا دور فعال جدا ومؤثر في معتاد
المعركه
وبالتالي سيد يعني تصورك لشكل الحروب
بالمستقبل هل سيختفي الجندي مثلا هل
سنتابع اشكالا جديده من القرصنه من
الدرونز متطوره يعني نسخ متطوره
هذا سؤال جميل جدا لان يقال ان الجيل
القادم من الطائرات القتاليه
يكون من دون التيار يعني حتى المقاتلات
والقذفات
غيرها من الطائرات الحربيه سوف تكون عديمه
التيار ولكن من جهه اخرى هناك عاملان
اساسيان لهما دور فعال جدا في المدن
المعركه قصدي جندي اي جندي يجب ان تكون
مهارته في استخدام السلاح عاريا جدا لانه
مهما كادت الدبابه متطوره مهما كان السلاح
مطورا الى عامل الاساسي هو مقاتل
في استخدامه والعمل الثاني مهاره القاده
لان جندي هو يحارب في موقعه والقائد هو
عنده صوره كامله عن
الجبهه باكملها والمنورات
ونقل القوات الى اخره اذا الشخص الانسان
لا يزال عاملا اساسيا وسيبقى لا يزال شكرا
جزيلا لك
سيد سارجي شاشكوف المحل العسكري الروسي
على كل هذه المعلومات
تحرك روسي جديد يدخل ضمن الصراع بين موسكو
والغرب هذه المره يهدف الى الغاء اتفاقيه
ذات طابع عسكري الامر الذي قد يؤدي الى
زياده في عدد الوحدات العسكريه في اوروبا
[موسيقى]
اتفاقيه القوات المسلحه التقليديه في
اوروبا معاهده عقدت بين النيتو وحلفوار
هدفت الى الحد من المعدات العسكريه
التقليديه في اوروبا
الزمت الاطراف الموقعه بتدمير كميات
الاسلحه الزائده عن حدود المعاهده
عدلت بعد انتهاء الحرب البارده في عام
الولايات المتحده سعت لنشر دفاعات صاروخيه
في اوروبا
على اثر ذلك طلبت روسيا تعديل المعاهده في
اجتماع عام 2007 رفض الطلب الروسي فعلقت
موسكو مشاركتها في الاتفاقيه في العاشر من
مارس 2015 قررت روسيا ايقاف مشاركتها
تماما اليوم تسعى روسيا من خلال مجلس
الدومه الى استنكار هذه الاتفاقيه
روسيا كانت قد انسحبت او علقت مشاركتها في
عدد من الاتفاقيات مع اورو
با واستعرض في العرض التالي تلك التعليقات
[موسيقى]
وصفت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه ان لينا
بيربوك الصين بانها منافس منهجي على
المسرح العالمي مؤكده ان بلادها تريد
العمل في شراكه مع الصين وانه من السذاجه
الاعتماد عليها كثيرا بما في ذلك القضايا
الامنيه على حد وصفها
سيكون التعاون افضل في جميع المجالات حتى
مع الصين لان الصين تعتبر بلدا مركزيا لكن
لا ينبغي ان نكون ساذجين لدرجه ان ندرك
عدم اهتمام الاخرين بالتعاون ولكن بصنع
التبعيات وفي حاله الشك التي تحولهم ضدنا
في القضايا الامنيه يحتاج المرء الى ادراك
اننا منافسون وللاسف نحن ايضا منافسون
منهجيون بشكل متزايد لان سياسه الصين قد
تغيرت ليس فقط على الصعيد المحلي ولكن
ايضا على الصعيد العالمي
الان مراسل العربيه يؤكد تجدد القصف على
مستوطنات غلاف تتابعون بعض الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه انها ستحمل قاده السودان
مسؤوليه استمرار العنف مشدده على انه لا
حل عسكريا للازمه في السودان واعربت
الخارجيه الامريكيه عن امتنانها للسعوديه
على استضافه محادثات بين طرفي الصراع
السودان
يعمل مع السعوديه للوصول الى وقف اطلاق
نار دائم في السودان واكدنا للشركاء
والحلفاء ان لا حل عسكريا للازمه نحن
ممتنون للسعوديه على استضافه محادثات جده
بين طرفي الصراع ونؤكد اننا سنحمل قاده
السودان مسؤوليه استمرار العنف
الصراع في السودان يقترب من اتمام شهره
الاول والاوضاع على الارض تبقى على صفيح
ساخن ميدانيا وقعت خسائر بشريه وايضا في
الممتلكات تحديدا بمنطقه بحري بعد مهاجمه
الجيش السوداني لاماكن تتمركز فيها قوات
الدعم السريع وفي وقت لاحق اعلنت قوات
الدعم السريع عبر صفحتها الرسميه اسقاط
طائره ثانيه تابعه للجيش في منطقه بحر
اضافه للسيطره على جسر الحلفايه الرابط
بين بحري وام درمان السياسيا تسعى الوساطه
السعوديه الامريكيه لاحداث اتفاق بين
الجيش والدعم السريع للتوصل الى وقف دائما
لاطلاق النار طبعا الجيش السوداني تمسك
بخروج غير مشروط لقوات الدعم السريع من
العاصمه وتجميع القوه في معسكر واحد وهو
ما رفضه الدعم السريع وفي اخر احصاء لعدد
الضحايا كشفت منظمه الصحه العالميه ان عدد
القتلى جراء الاشتباكات في السودان تجاوز
600 قتيل واكثر من خمسه الاف جريح حتى
الان اليوم اعلنت نقابه اطباء السودان في
بيان ان 27 مستشفى تعمل بشكل كامل او حتى
جزئي في عموم ارجاء السودان من اصل 88
مستشفى محذره من انهيار القطاع الصحي
الصراع في السودان وكما ذكرنا يوم امس ادى
لنزوح اكثر من 700 الف شخص داخل البلاد
وفرار 150 الف شخص لدول مجاوره بينما توقع
برنامج الاغذيه العالميه التابع للامم
المتحده ان يعاني ما يصل الى مليونين
وخمسمائه الف سوداني من الجوع بالاشهر
المقبله ما يرفع عدد من يعانون من انعدام
الامن الغذائي الحاد هناك الى تسعه عشره
مليون
التحيه ليكم والله بنرجع
بنقور الفجر كده
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
وكشفت مصادر مقربه من قائد الجيش السوداني
الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان ان الاخيره
كاد ان يفقد حياته خلال الساعات الاولى من
بدء الصراع على يد قوات الدعم السريع بعد
اقتحامها مقر القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه وسط العاصمه الخرطوم تفاصيل اكثر
عن هذه النقطه تحديدا في التقرير التالي
خلال ساعه الاولى من بدء صراع في السودان
كان قائد القوات المسلحه عبد الفتاح
البرهان في مواجهه مباشره كادت تنهي حياته
معلومات كشفتها وكاله رويترز للمره الاولى
تقول ان قوات الدعم السريع اشتبكت مباشره
مع البرهان وحراسه الشخصي في مقر القياده
العامه للجيش السوداني بعد عمليه اقتحام
شنها افراد من قوات الدعم السريع على
المبنى بحسب المعلومات التي نقلتها رويترز
عما وصفته بحارس شخصي للفريق اول عبد
الفتاح البرهان فان الساعات الاولى كانت
حاسمه في الصراع وتسببت بمقتل العشرات
وفقا لشهاده حارس البرهان فان القوات
المهاجمه قتلت 30 عنصرا من حراس البرهان
واجبرت المواجهه قائد الجيش على القتال
بنفسه بواسطه كلاشنكوف قبل ان ينقله حراسه
الى مكان امن لتنسحب قوات الدعم السريع من
المكان عقب العمليه
العمليه الخاطفه كشفت عن الاسلوب المفضل
لخصم البرهان الفريق اول محمد حمدان دقلو
المعروف باسم حميتي وهو القتال من مسافات
قريبه واستغلال نقاط القوه لدى قوته امر
قد يفسر استمرار تمدرس قوات الدعم السريع
في عده مناطق بالعاصمه السودانيه حتى
اللحظه وغير هذا وذا قد يفسر سبب تعنت كل
من الخصمين في الحسم العسكري فروايه
الساعات الاولى تقول انها بدات حاسمه
وبنيه القتل رائد المصطفى العربي
[موسيقى]
طلبت الحكومه الباكستانيه الجيش بالتدخل
الفوري لحفظ الامن في العاصمه حيث تشهد
الشوارع اعمال شغب واعتداءات على الاماكن
العامه من قبل مؤيدي رئيس الحكومه السابق
عمران خان من جهه اخرى قرر قاضي التحقيق
تمديد احتجاز عمران خان لمده ثمانيه ايام
ورفض القاضي طلب محاميه بالافراج عنه
[موسيقى]
في مقابلات خاصه لقناه العربيه لزميل طاهر
بركه اشار رئيس حزب العداله والتنميه في
ولايه اسطنبول عثمان نوري كباكتبه بان
اولويات حزب العداله والتنميه في
الانتخابات الحاليه هو التفكير المواطنين
بان تركيا باتت تنافس الدول المتقدمه في
مجالات عده دون ان يتطرق الى اعاده هيمنه
التيارات الاسلاميه او المحافظين على
الحكم او الاقتصاد
[موسيقى]
كل انتخابات نخوضها تتطلب تجديدا وما
نقصده هو نقل تركيا الى مراحل متقدمه من
التطور فقد غدت تركيا اليوم دوله تصنع
طائراتها الحربيه بنفسها بعد ان كانت
تستورد حتى عجلاتها من الخارج ورفعت عدد
مطاراتها من 20 مطارا الى 60 وصارت تصنع
سياراتها بعد ان كانت تستورد اصغر
المنتجات الصناعيه وستغدو من الدول
المخابره والمعدوده في التكنولوجيا الفضاء
والصحه وما وصلت اليه في التعليم نحن
واثقون من دعم المواطنين لنا في انتخابات
القرن التركي
في خضم الاصتافات والتحالفات في تركيا
يبرز اسم تحالف العمل والحريه والذي يشكل
حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي الكردي الاساسي
ونقطه القوى الاكبر فيه لذلك سعى مرشح
المعارضه الرئيسيه كمالك الى كسب ودي هذا
التحالف
ونجح بالفعل بالحصول على دعمهم في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه فقط اما في
الانتخابات البرلمانيه فاكره الطرفين
يتنافسان في صناديق الاقتراح
في الانتخابات البلديه الماضيه دعم حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي مرشحين معارضه في المدن
الكبرى كانقر واسطنبول فخسر مرشحون
لائتلاف حاكم هذه المدن لاول مره منذ
عقدين دعم الحزب في الغالبيه الكرديه كان
حاسما هذه المعادله لن تتغير في
الانتخابات القادمه من ناحيه الشكل لكنها
تغيرت لجهه مضمون
لم يستطع الحزب الذي يحظى بدعم في المناطق
الكرديه من الانضمام لتحالف الامه المعارض
لرفض حزب الخير القومي المتشدد وزعيمته
ميرال اكشنر التعامل العلني والمباشره مع
الحزب لان القوميين ينظرون اليه كامتدادا
لحزب العمال الكردستاني لكن في المقابل لم
تمانع اكشنر من تواصل شريكها في تحالف
الامه كمال كلجدار اوغلو مع قاده الحزب
الكردي لكسب ودهم وضمان تاييدهم وفق هذه
المعادله بقيت العلاقه بين تحالف الامه
وحزب الشعوب قائمه لسنوات تعاون من تحت
الطاوله ودعم كردي لمرشحي التحالف لكن حزب
الشعوب الذي اراد اعترافا علنيا بدوره
وحقوق الاكراد من قبل تحالف الامه يدرك
تماما استحاله انضمامه لهذا التحالف لذلك
قرر التحالف العمل والحريه جاذبا اليه
احزابا يساريه صغيره
الاستبيانات والاحصاءات بالاضافه الى
الدورات الانتخابيه السابقه اظهرت بلا
ادنى شك بان الاصوات الكرديه المحسوبه على
حزب الشعب الديمقراطي هي عنصر توازن مهم
في الانتخابات وعليه ستبقى الاصوات
الكرديه عنصرا مهما وسيكون لها دور كبير
في تحديد مسار التصويت ينصب هدف هذا
التحالف مباشره على الانتخابات البرلمانيه
ودخول البرلمان باكبر عدد من النواب لكنه
فضل عدم طرح مرشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه
ودعم مرشح تحالف الامه كمال كلجدار اوغلو
ضد اردوغان فكل التحالفين يريدان ازاحه
اردوغان عن المشهد
الكردي يمتاز بوعي سياسي عال يمكنه من
تحديد مصلحته في الانتخابات وحزبنا يثق
بوعي الناخب الكردي الذي سيتجه نحو
التصويت لصالح المرشح الذي يختاره الحزب
ساعات الجدار اوغلو بقوه للحصول على دعم
هذا التحالف عبر تقديمه وعودا قاطعه
بمناقشه القضيه الكرديه في البرلمان لكن
مدى استجابه الاكراد لدعوه التحالف
بالتصويت لزعيم المعارضه لا يبدو واضحا
حتى اللحظه فحسابات الانتخابات البلديه
لدى الناخب تختلف تماما عن حساباته في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
يشكل الغاء الدوله في البنوك التركيه جزءا
من السياسه الماليه غير التقليديه للرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان لخفض التضخم المرتفع مع
الاستمرار بتطبيق اسعار فائده منخفضه
ولجعل الليره وسيله لتبادل الوحيده في
المعاملات التجاريه المحليه فما الذي
سيحدث بعد الانتخابات
كثفت القيود على البنوك التركيه
واتخذت اجراءات احترازيه تحسبا لاي انخفاض
في قيمه الليره بعد انتخابات الرابع عشر
من مايو عده قرارات من المركزي التركي
للبنوك نصت على الحد من بيع الدولارات
للشركات التي ليست بحاجه ملحه لسداد
مستحقاتها مقابل منح الاولويه لاصحاب
الودائع بالليره ضمن النظام الادخار
الذي تبلغ قيمته حاليا 100 مليار دولار
هذا النظام اطلق عام 2021 عندما شهدت
الليره التركيه ازمه وارتفع التضخم لاعلى
مستوى في 24 عاما بسبب سياسه اردوغان
الاقتصاديه غير التقليديه فهي شديده
التيسير مقابل تضخم مرتفع بلغ الشهر
الماضي 44%
قواعد مصرفيه اخرى لرفع نسبه ودائع البنوك
بالليره الى 65% خلال النصف الاول من
العام الحالي فاذا قلت عن نسبه 60% فعلى
البنوك ايداع جزء اكبر من الودائع
بالعملات الاجنبيه لدى المركزي وشراء سبعه
في المئه اضافيه من السندات الحكوميه
بالعمله المحليه اما اذا زادت تلك النسبه
فستعفى البنوك من الاحتفاظ ببعض السندات
الحكوميه بالعمله المحليه ومن جانبها
ترستاندرد ان تلك القواعد ستؤثر على
الارباح السنويه لمقرضي تركيا وتتعثر ثقه
المستثمرين فيما لا يزال القلق مسيطرا على
حركه العمله فكل من وكاله فيتش وجولدن
توقعوا ان تشهد اللير مزيدا من الضغوط بعد
الانتخابات وتتعرض اسهم البنوك لتقلبات
حاده اذا ما اتخذت السياسه الماليه شكلا
جديدا ما يؤدي الى انكماش
القطاعات منظمات غير حكوميه فرنسا بارتكاب
انتهاكات جسيمه لحقوق المهاجرين على
حدودها مع اسبانيا فرنسا حسب التقرير
الحقيقي تعرض المهاجرين لنفس المعامله
المسيئه التي تمارسها على حدودها
الايطاليه
[موسيقى]
منظمات حقوقيه تتهم فرنسا باساءه معامله
المهاجرين على حدودها مع اسبانيا وايطاليا
بين 2019
و2022
رصدت المنظمات عمليات تفتيش تميزيه
واعاده طالبي اللجوء من ذوي الملامح
السمراء تعرضوا للتنطيط العرقي والترحيل
القصري السريع حسب التقرير السلطات
الفرنسيه شددت المراقبه على 37 نقطه عبور
الامر الذي دفع بالمهاجرين الى المرور
بمناطق واعره
المخاطر ادت الى مقتل ما لا يقل عن 12
شخصا
[موسيقى]
هناك فرصه للعمل المشترك بين دمشق انقره
بمساعده ودعم موسكو و طهران التصريح هو
لوزير الخارجيه السوري فيصل المقداد من
موسكو اما توقيته فهو عقب اجتماع رباعي ضم
المقداد مع نظرائه الروسيه والايراني
والتركي ولا ننسى ان هذا اللقاء هو الاول
الذي يجتمع فيه وزيره خارجيه سوريا وتركيا
بعد اكثر من عقد عن من القطيع
اليوم من رمزي صمود البلاد وهدف روسيا
القديم الجديد انها ضخمه ام المعارك
اوكرانيا واطوالها في هذه المدينه
المهجوره لم يعد للوقت معنا لن تستطيع
تحديد ليلك من نهارك والسبب نيران المدى
لكنك حتما سافرى بوضوح الموتى والدمار
اما صوره اليوم فمن الحدود المكسيكيه
الامريكيه مهاجرون تجمعوا امام الجدار
الحدودي ينتظرون تسليم انفسهم الى حرس
الحدود الامريكي وذلك بعد انقضاء قيود
كوفيد التي كانت تجعل من المستحيل طلب
اللجوء بهذه الطريقه تجمع هؤلاء ولسان
حالهم يقول اتيت تاركا وراء كل شيء انها
نهايه الطريق وبدايه الامل لم يتبقى للحلم
سوى هذا الجدار
الزميل صهيب بابات جاهزا ومعه اهم اخبار
الساعه مساء الخير مساء الخير راويه
بالفعل جوله سريعه شامله ومتنوعه من اخبار
اليوم في اخبار الساعه بعد قليل في
الصداره التطورات في غزه المزيد من
الصواريخ يتم اطلاقها وكذلك الغارات
الاسرائيليه نتابع الوضع من هناك شكرا لك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات